I'm embarrassed I'm embarrassed but by
our opening and Sam is not here today so
of course just being Anthony and is your
Mike on the hole make sure I turns you
on
oh you're on yeah oh I am hot yup oh oh
oh I would be embarrassed out of this
this oh yeah we just need it to be like
shitty and like this will be mission
accomplished becomes the intro yeah yeah
you know it works for a morning radio
show it does yeah yeah I got up it was
nighttime there was still night time out
when I woke up to come here cuz I was
out on Long Island I didn't stay in oh
yes a say so I had to get on the train
but like when I take the train it's
usually off-peak and now it was it was
just full and I was annoyed with
everybody I just really am not a people
person surprised well you used to it now
if you're taking [ __ ] after work
you're done by 6:00 yeah nothing it's
it's it's great it's two out and I was
looking at people and and I was they do
this every day and I understand the
hardship of that I'm like look at what I
did when I could choose when I wanted to
work I said four to six pm yeah and four
and because it's too much four days away
what a lazy piece of [ __ ] you're a man
of leisure a man of leisure so uh four
to six are perfect it seems like a
really fun schedule that's what so many
people have asked me to like when you
did that what did you have did you do
any studies did you did you look and see
when people would listen or test
anything I'm like no I could be up by 4
to work and after 6 I could still hang
out and you know go out what's have you
typically get up oh wow
like a noon noonish is good yeah
sometimes Monday Monday Wednesday and
Friday I have my trainer so that's at
11:30 so I have to get up earlier for
that
but given the opportunity just I will
get bedsores I will stay in bed I do not
care to wake up and do anything you do
it Friday - they see that to me like the
day off the [ __ ] first day I don't
have to wake up I never want to get up
and do anything no it's because Thursday
night I'm up so late that I sleep in
Friday
I don't sleep because I went to sleep at
8:00 p.m. the night before and then I
sleep until all hours yeah I'm up until
probably 4 or 5 a.m.
the other trainer on Fridays on a
nightly basis yeah yeah I do so I wake
up early on Friday but it's an early is
in early it's 11 o'clock yeah so even if
I go to bed at 5:00 it's it's enough
hours I'm on the road on the road I go
to bed like 6 7 in the morning it's
[ __ ] horrible they're a little
sleeping habits I'm the worst I know I
woke up this morning refreshed after I
went to bed like right before 12:00 when
I woke up at 7 and I felt like I dozed
off eight minutes ago
really ah yeah I I it reminded me a
little bit of when I used to do mornings
right here and as the hours no I was I
was like how the [ __ ] did I do this like
they literally had to pile tons of money
at me so I would wake up and even then I
missed a few yes yes I remember I
remember the Kenny calls hi Anthony it's
6 o'clock and then you have that panicky
you you're you're already late and
you're still in bed 30 miles from the
biggest city in the world and there's
gonna be more traffic than a [ __ ] at
that hours of the would have been at 5
a.m. yeah and I'd be you know driving in
the but it was cool everybody was
cheering when I got here yeah yeah I
know I'm I was really happy to walk into
because we were having such a good time
on my god [ __ ] now I can join the fun
yeah yeah join the fun not be looked at
it was awful shitty cocktail out of a
[ __ ] doom actually quiet fun
some men are gonna do some joking clear
the field not oh god yeah I try real
hard to let me come in the morning to
not have any tension like you know yeah
it's a job but I always say to myself
don't do this don't be like that don't
be that [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's always a problem no it you could
really take a step back look at
everything and go yeah this is pretty
good this is a pretty good gig and and
you go in and you know you're gonna be
having fun when I'm doing my show
hanging out with Artie Lange yeah and
we're laughing our asses off and other
comics are there and the staff is [ __ ]
awesome
there's no one that I walk in and dread
like oh [ __ ] you know what what what is
that gonna be like today your show is
good too man it's Anthony and Artie of
course a for the sick you compound media
it's amazing you took that from like
just your basement and you built this
this this this network were you gonna
[ __ ] like a different show like
you're the boss I know it's crazy I
really can't accept that either cuz
people do they go hey boss so I'm like
shut up please I don't want to be the
boss some people understand this is
going to be a thread through the first
hour yes you do Geoffrey have some wine
Christ
exactly yeah it's a it is weird though
it's um and we get new shows coming on
after the new year a couple more news
oriented girl you know gonna get a
really a lady on board okay not know
what kind of show yeah like a a news
type show public like news current
issues and things like that but a lady a
ladies take on the whole thing and she's
been around some of the network news
shows and stuff so it's pretty cool okay
only I'm gonna guess I won't say it Oh
does it does
I mean begin with that's the first name
okay yeah cool I think she'll be really
good I hope it's the same one ah
and this in the second with a second
name
it's just my uh oh no no oh no it's it's
a oh it's the it's it's this oh okay
yeah yeah okay I thought okay I guess
Megan Kelly I was wrong
yeah we just have a few million laying
around for for that I think she know
she's really not she's uh where is she
at the Today Show or something yeah she
went off of Fox Fox is its own little
island yeah and it's different than a
lot of the other mainstream media so
when you leave there it does not
necessarily mean you're gonna do well in
the the pool of liberal media she stood
out there I thought she was great and
she was nothing tough and I loved her
and now it's like who cares yeah I saw
some clip last week or the week before
and she was she was up dancing like
doing that whole thing to try to you
know get something going when they have
to dance yes no good Kalen pulled it off
let's be all kidding aside I love an
Ellen dances - yeah good-natured it's
fun kids do you like when she picks
somebody else in the crowd that she
wants to [ __ ] muff dive on give the
secret little dance like birds she
really does she starts like bumping
dances with some of the ladies in the
audience yeah I know how is that not
harassment that's a problem I would
think I think that's a problem I'm
starting to think everybody is up for a
sexual harassment charge of something
because it all it takes is an allegation
and I think if you look at everyone's
life especially not in the context of
2017 everyone has done something sure
that could be considered even if it's
you know addressing a girls clothing or
something like that oh that's nice hey
you look great today ah Jeffrey Tambor's
he might leave he might leave yeah a
parent because I don't know what
happened with the assistant but what
would he do it the other woman who plays
a yoga instructor I've only seen season
one it was
he was that bit he [ __ ] she said he
made a couple of comments like MIT you
know I want to have sex with you like
butthole like being over the top but
then she said she was stand there to
kind of dry humped her but he said he
was I guess he was kidding
guys it's fine but it came off as like
he was trying to be funny I guess but it
didn't come almost funny there's a weird
thing and especially in Hollywood and
Washington because they they have that
power and the media where you know you I
think you just completely forget that
you're not supposed to act like that in
in social settings I think these people
have been told yes their whole lives and
how amazing they are and how everyone
loves them that they honestly believe
they could just go up and start humping
people and I don't honestly like you
just said I don't think that's the worst
thing though that anyone's done I've
seen that happen plenty of times but you
know today oof getting fired in 2002 it
has prevented me from having so many
problems today you can Mack his young
eager [ __ ] couple of years in a radio
Jimmy Norton thought that we were
untouchable and the minute oh no you're
not yeah and that firing convinced me
that I'm replaceable it made me I can
get fired from any gig I have I have
been [ __ ] paranoid at work for 15
years about your backup and possibly
getting fired that's a that's a yeah I I
absolutely agree with you on that one
when we came back to satellite radio and
almost [ __ ] it up within weeks of
being there with the homeless guy
whatever that was homeless Charlie no he
was uh when did homeless charlie
happened that wasn't that was 2006 that
was the merger where the merger was
happening oh the merger was happening
yeah yeah yeah it was me you boo Toby
Anthony me Bill burr and he was in
studio that day and yeah that guy the
homeless guy came in and we were like
wow satellite radio is a great place for
just let this homeless guy voice his
wacky nutty opinions yeah and he started
going off about raping the Queen of
England who is that Bush [ __ ] yeah
you're talking about he said like that
dumb character I do yeah he said he was
some who
Laura Bush rape the core of Bush and
Condoleezza Rice enter right cut yes oh
yes we meant I think it's we was talking
about how laser eyes yeah and it was
just like we were laughing cuz it's
here's a crazy homeless guy and we we
got called in they started getting
complaints and Reverend Al started
chiming in and it was we were just
looking at each other like are you
[ __ ] kidding are we gonna blow this
again suspended we were suspended for a
month so we get for a month because it's
better for a month and k-rock who
apparently other agents are talking to
we we got put we were on Carrick and
that was the only thing that saved the
show was yeah k-rock satellite booted us
for a month yes yeah we were suspended
and then yeah yeah I was going home and
watching a loss at the time that was
when I caught up on lawsuit we would do
k-rock instead of walking over to XM we
could we had the month off we would just
go home I 9:00 in the morning I'm like
this is [ __ ] great it was awesome
going home eating fruit salad and
watching lost that was my days for a
month but that was when I was on when I
went k-rock tried getting rid of me
Kid Rock wanted me off the show cuz they
thought I was the problem with the
ratings right and after that when we
were just desperate to hang on then I
started doing the [ __ ] I just was
coming in five days E and they'd come to
have me down to three days a week where
was ridiculous it was stupid but I
didn't care I was warming up for monster
rain so I was going away doing [ __ ]
uh I would do like Sun a Thursday
through Sunday and just come back in and
dude fly home Monday and do Tuesday
through Thursday with you guys so it
actually worked out okay that's when I
know I needed to go to a Tom chiisana
for a justice no he was absolutely yeah
he [ __ ] he was one of the ones I
think that was gunning for me so I've
been about anyway after that we got
suspended I just started coming in again
there was no more talking about yeah hey
Rock was worried we were gonna get fired
do you remember Anthony's completely
sincere apology yeah it was really good
but it was not right on K rocks airwaves
it was a I wish we had
god I wanna hear guys see if you can
tell how sincere you this was when we
came back from being suspended for yeah
this was on satellite but it didn't play
it did not play on okay I didn't have to
we weren't suspended from there so well
I think I think it it was on both really
no we did that key rock I don't believe
it was played on although was it I don't
know I feel like you guys did too
apologies I feel like you apologized at
k-rod over the show and then when we
went over to XM bone-dry good morning
got to take this opportunity first right
off the bat here cyanide to take instead
of opportunity that is really you could
tell right away I had right away this
was written for us oh yeah obviously I'm
not gonna sit there in pen yeah an
apology well I know it was written for
you because I remember you crumpling up
the paper
that's right rowing it away after yes
that would be indication was the crinkle
of the paper I think you didn't hear it
on the air I don't remember correctly
I'm watching you do it yeah they told us
we had to apologize oh gotta take this
opportunity first right off the bat here
because of things that have happened of
course have to apologize to public
officials for comments that were made on
our XM show on may 9th we take very
seriously the responsibility that comes
with our creative freedom and regret any
offence that the segment that we're
talking about has caused so what
definitely apologize for that want to
take this opportunity you had to though
like that's a livid yeah that was on
character I was like yeah save the show
yeah that's save the show that dumb
moment right there is what finally
allowed that remember was on Breitbart
and it did the headline read will this
effect
merger and that will yeah yeah we're
like oh boy
throw that show away or you know weigh
it out the huge merger that was taking
place yeah
that had to actually get federal
approval yeah and we're standing in the
way yeah we're gonna stand by our guys
here
screw the merger and we were all just
laughing at [ __ ] homeless Charlie who
was funny by the way and I was still
Larry I came back in today he was a hoot
that guy he really was I think I was a
laugh riot great timing weird time man
that was a [ __ ] weird time going home
at 9:00 a.m. was what was so weird about
it being finished at nine o'clock and I
kind of like I liked it from you know
knowing we were coming back on in a
month and Eric Logan saved us but he
couldn't he couldn't save us from that
monster special yeah knowing that we
were okay and we were gonna be coming
back was really cool when we were done
at nine I mean freedom er to walk over
for those people that that were like
just serious subscribers we did the walk
over was so much fun that that that five
minute walk from k-rock to to XM and
then dead the [ __ ] pushing a cart
like Danny and whoever would put your
thing would push the cart that had the
accordionist that had like satellite
equipment something to like microwave
equipment
so that they could broadcast us while we
walked from one block to another one
block was like one city block and just
whatever was happening on the streets we
would comment about it Patrice would be
there and whatever other comic was was
on the show that day would be there
Jimmy would go to the newsstand and
trying to buy black honcho black inches
haunt you I think what under hopefully
black is still going strong
that's right enforcement running
Starbucks and do those comedy yeah yeah
and that cakes would be destroyed that's
right
ir dr orange oh poor poor andrew Orfila
wonder how he's doing
you know I want to know whatever
happened to him he there was one day he
just disappeared maybe he moved or maybe
he went store warmer or
yeah oh well hope he's okay
he probably doesn't have a job either I
think he's probably also Facebook show
yeah dunsky
yeah enough oh my god poor Manson died I
know I liked his earlier work he became
a hack at the end but it earlier stuff
he was cutting infants out of the
[ __ ] room his uh I realized today
because I start tweet that's how I I
didn't I don't check their news Megan uh
Amram you know she she's a really funny
file on Twitter and she tweeted upside
to Charles Manson's death we get a new
candle in the wind very good so Manson
is gone yeah eighty-three years old you
know I don't know when when you say life
in prison without the possibility of
parole against the death penalty you
know do you think Charles Manson was
really that that bad off in prison for
83 years I know he took a beating once
and you know but he lived out his life
he got three three square meals a day
yeah hots and a cot 300 cot roof over
his head and he lived to you know pretty
good age 83 how much time did he do
before this will you talk about this
today how much time did he do before the
murders he had done time in prison first
I don't know how much it was I'm once it
was it was it like 15 or 20 years he had
done or ten years really yeah he had
done a decent amount of time in prison
and then he can't got out and he proved
that he was not going to be a great very
good yeah yeah wow that's uh that's
[ __ ] up though 83 years old and that
was his life sentence what did he die of
give cancer a hard problem just old just
an old guy just an old guy he died of
being 83 yeah but it's like you know you
get some people that are just amazing
and good to the world and they drop dead
30
yeah
and you know you get this guy 83 years
old there is no God I know and then he
sent Roman Polanski off into a spiral oh
my god I'm grieving how old are you get
a hot tub [ __ ] creep
it is funny that with with like
Hollywood kind of doing this purge and
some guys are you know [ __ ] disguise
there's guys in Hollywood who are just
and everywhere that you look at you like
oh like that person is a complete piece
of [ __ ]
how is Roman Polanski of all these
people all these other allegations how
is this guy not being ashamed into
moviemaking they love him him and you
know Woody Allen's another piece of [ __ ]
think about that but he's only had one
and I think I say only wanted me let me
let me let me let me amend this he's
only had one I don't mean he's only
allegedly molested one five-year-old but
I mean it's like this is my word against
your type thing yeah and the other
stepdaughter he married so but but
that's kind of that's the weird part I
think yeah I don't even think the malla
station part that the that is alleged is
the weirdest part it's the the actual he
married his his stepdaughter to me I
always thought that was a career saving
move you think yeah I am in II loved her
but I always thought that was a career
saving I got caught doing something bad
and like I gotta save it and this will
save it well back then I guess it could
have nowadays you're done now you're G
just seems you're done well it's gonna
be interesting to see who comes back
from all these things like some people I
honestly believe will come back
I think Louie yeah is you know what
Louis everyone can kind of grasp onto
what Louie did wanna not grasp on we've
seen him he's a funny stand-up people
get something from him like like again
yeah anything I say you know you go to
one of your shows you're laughing yes
gonna dressing its Gallagher onstage you
get but you see like a producer or
something
you're so removed from that and most
people don't even know what okay where
to produce it does it's Harvey Weinstein
you just see this [ __ ] monster
walking around so I think Lou you'll do
fine I think in time people just like
what Louis does he's a likable guy
and I think he'll be fine in time plus
if this is all it seems like this is all
there is this is all there is and it's
all over ten years ago and he thought he
was good and there's ways for him to
come even though I can write its kind of
creepy at work but but it's like he's
still a [ __ ] he's not a rapist he's a
guy I don't think he looked at it like
he was making victims other people know
he's went with the words I asked and she
said yes that's Louise autism you know
he said can I do this and she went yes
and I did it you know for him the
literal the literal yes and no of the
word right right that that is just what
an awkward thing to want to do nice
weird I think it's something if you've
been in a relationship for a while and
and there's this mutual masturbation
thing and it goes along with other stuff
maybe I don't know but but just to say
hey pleased to meet you I'm gonna pull
my dick out now and and start pounding
on it it just seems a little weird I'm
not an exhibitionist though like I'm I'm
more of a voyeur like I'd rather watch I
don't know I don't know the I don't feel
naughty with a girl watching me jerk off
I just feel embarrassed like completely
naked forget it he got completely naked
dude I jerked off recently with a girl
and a [ __ ] like a little video thing
and [ __ ] I still because I come far
I'm digressing here i dude I always put
a touch I don't want to show my little
gut it's not that much but you know it's
a [ __ ] bit so I lift up my shirt so I
don't come on and I put a tent
it's the unsexiest thing but I'm so
embarrassed even to this day about my
body that I have to have a [ __ ] lie
got a paper towel so you'll know I'm
gonna come when I put like a little
cheaper towels on my chest just tie a
lobster bib around what a weird thing to
do though want to wanting to jack off in
front of us I just don't I don't
understand yeah but I don't see it as
being all that creepy and yeah and
another thing like when two girls come
up to a [ __ ] hotel room like that I
don't know I think they want something
too not sexual maybe or something but I
think there's a quid pro quo
Oh going on when they come up to the
room like that maybe sometimes I don't
know them I don't know what they were
doing it's a little early in Louie's
career at that point he wasn't like like
famous Louie right but still I think
these two girls probably thought it
would be good for them to go up there
now what are they getting out of it I
don't know but they must have thought
something and then there's Louie going
well I know what I want out of it I want
to jack off in front of you what are
they doing something like like oh my god
he can't believe is gonna do that and
he's thinking like yeah they want to
wash me
this times like these guys we delude
ourselves read the signals wrong like
they're being like they're uncomfortable
and like what the [ __ ] he doing like
yeah go ahead whatever they're doing and
he's like oh god they're enjoying like
we [ __ ] miss reading each other
sometimes like I think we do mysteries a
lot and I you know I've been talking
about this recent like when you look at
[ __ ] how old people got together yeah
how you know the woman would go like oh
I never wanted to go out with him but he
was just so persistent and I wound up
going out with him and next thing you
know I married and let's say your
grandparents man talk to you [ __ ]
grandparents about how they'd be it
wasn't it's not a nice like oh you know
I I we both had a mutual respect for
each other it was uh you know I didn't
know I said no to him at first and then
he took a metal lunchbox and hit my
boyfriend of teeth and I said all right
I'll go out with him and take the
notebook walk film she's on a date with
this guy that [ __ ] [ __ ] blocker is
coming up and hanging on the ferris
wheel and you're not picking up on the
signals you're interrupting and ruining
something so I don't know maybe he just
misread and maybe he thought that they
were enjoying watching him but his penis
but I think in a lot of these instances
that were seeing people being accused of
harassment and and a behavior that is so
inappropriate
I really think these girls are kind of
laughing and stuff I know one of the
girls from from Fox News she she was
actually on on I think one of the
network news shows talking about her
run-in with Harvey Weinstein Lauren yeah
Lauren and and when she tells the
stories and told the stories over the
course of years to her friends it was
one of the funniest stories you'd hear
because she was telling it like and this
pulls his dick out and he's doing it
like it only becomes this serious thing
when the woman wants it to be a serious
thing and it always seems like there's
some purpose behind it I don't know I
think he's a creep [ __ ] I think
he did a lot of nasty [ __ ] but I think a
lot of these women in a lot of these
instances just they thought it was funny
- at the sign of my goofy
he was rapey though I think I'll say
that last I think I think so remember we
interviewed him yeah yeah that's the
email thanking us for a good time and a
lot of laughs what a shock where the
people he gets along with that was yeah
I totally forgot we had we had
interviewed him what's up Barry sure how
are you buddy Ari yeah
sit down got the winter we're on hate it
it's nighttime when you get up we're
just talking about it by the time it's
6:00 for like 4 p.m. it's it's getting
dark I like that though I hate it
because I'm shady and I'm a seedy
individual yes you like sorry gonna open
the cover yeah I like the cover of
darkness I really don't like anything
dark but I love it [ __ ] I like
getting up with his pitch black and I
like my four o'clock it's dark really
yeah I don't like a cold but I love the
[ __ ] shadiness a bit just being dark
and uncomfortably secretive out of my
nighttime dark morning dark just seems
like what the [ __ ] you doing with your
life well I'm wrapped in shame so I like
it I like it dark and I can just kind of
you know be secret I don't know after
like three hours of afternoon darkness
when I look outside and think it's been
dark for three hours and the Sun would
still be up in the summer and I could be
out by the pool or something hanging out
having fun but I'm inside you know [ __ ]
that don't you wish you Jacuzzi was
year-round yeah I [ __ ] up now it's all
tied in plumbing lies to the pool so
everything has to be shut down in the
winter and then everything gets opened
up in
because it goes into the have you been
in his house yeah it's amazing but the
jacuzzi goes over into the puts a go
waterfall yeah the waterfall goes in
there I mean I like the time away from
summer activities but I just can't stay
on the cold yeah I like a nice winter
jacuzzi which I'll occasionally go
outside and get in the old jacuzzi and
the we like that in Aspen where you
could jack off in front of girl under
the surface you got this boner that
nobody knows about should have done I
think I can't get a [ __ ] rod in the
jacuzzi I mean I've gotten turned on
briefly but I can't do anything really
sexual in the jacuzzi the water doesn't
turn me on i water's a [ __ ] man I've
done it once but the weird thing is like
the vagina I'm just like like it's like
a water balloon it just fills up to
where it's like you're not doing it also
too weird feeling pumping water into it
and you did the lubrication is gone
we're just like push-pull things like a
warren squeegee from a homeless guy like
an old windshield wiper that smells like
fish oh wait yeah I don't I don't [ __ ]
in the water ever and I don't like it
yeah it's C it's one of those things
that is supposed to be so romantic and
cool and and stuff and it's just it
doesn't work it's hot the old movies and
so it's not good I remember a girl
wanted to [ __ ] on in the ocean on
vacation down in like the Bahamas and
stuff and it I'm like there's no [ __ ]
way I'm pulling my dick out i watch TV I
see nature shows a male dick is exactly
like food those fish and Jim
[Laughter]
I would never try to [ __ ] in the water
like that yeah no I wouldn't either I
wouldn't either in salt water in your
mouth the male Jack yes no just it just
does it you kind of hangs there like a
like bait yeah it's just not a sexy
field being a little nutters not a sexy
feeling it just doesn't feel good it
doesn't turn me on now
sexual places you guys are I'm too
self-conscious and paranoid that I'm
gonna be caught but there was something
cool years ago about outside like the
woods like outside for Long Island
that's like a thing you'd go into the
woods drink smoke a little weed and then
[ __ ] your girl kind of work in the woods
like up against the tree or something
cuz it was weird you're outside a
Petrelli the [ __ ] paradise lost'
documentary no there was something about
the woods which was kind of dirty and
sexy and naughty those yeah like someone
could be watching or something I don't
like that some people get off on on oh I
think we could be being watched I don't
[ __ ] want that I don't either no
creepy occasional do it like a hotel
room way up high we're like looking
watch us you leave the windows open yeah
yeah so I mean yeah at top you keep a
ride if you think people are watching
only
really yeah I don't like it's a problem
like you're a real exhibition I could
keep it rod as if I was in a hotel
shooting out of the Mirage yeah well
that's not referencing the tragedy
you're saying a new a new one right
right I yeah I I can't be watched having
sex one time I was in Vegas and I forget
the girl I picked up at the pool or
whatever it was and I was in the room
and [ __ ] dice wanted to watch him in
Kenny and happy face oh come on once in
a while when I would do the Venetian
with them dice would get me a suite they
would sometimes have an extra suite and
they would just upgrade the opener it
was just once it like once every three
appearances I'll get a [ __ ] sweet
so the suite had two entrances through
like you go through the bathroom and
peek in the bedroom or from the main
living room area go to the bathroom
so those guys went hang out a living
when I take the girl in the bedroom and
they'd sneak in the bathroom and watch
and I remember not being able to keep a
rod as I was fooling around or cuz I saw
them peeking in oh man dice would always
want to ruin it yeah I'm gonna be
enticed listening a man Cal get laid we
were just sitting there [ __ ]
nose-to-nose our ear and I'm like this
is what's on my dick but this man came I
was [ __ ] this girl and this is many
many years ago I mean dicey just knows
to know it was the weirdest that's yeah
was after we did two nights at this
theater in Chicago and like he's gonna
try to kiss me it just got so yeah that
watching watching be like like I said
the voyeuristic thing yeah but I like
watching but I don't I don't like
watching a guy [ __ ] a girl like I
would love watching a girl just
masturbating herself on a bed or
something you know [ __ ] no I don't know
I was on the way home two months
when I pass on the ground floor some
with the window open just [ __ ]
yesterday watch why and I walk by and it
moves grunts so I was like what I walked
past again but and then I just went
across the street and Sammis to and
pretended to be in my phone like a crazy
yeah yeah I'm looking at it cuz I was
far enough away no one can a mite you
know if you if you leave your window
there they call expectation of privacy
if you leave your window open on the
first floor yeah like you you kind of
want people that would freak me out to
be first I can rape my girl it would
freak me out so much there was one time
though me and Jimmy actually [ __ ] our
perspective once remember that all the
way home from Santa I couldn't get a rod
Anthony was a [ __ ] animal Anthony was
a [ __ ] face in the neck animal I
fooled about did she might have suck my
dick or I might even [ __ ] I'm a
terrible
I'm a terrible [ __ ] the worst experience
of my life was watching Florentine [ __ ]
a girl while I was wearing all black I
said I was just like the preacher from
poltergeist ooh and I'm eating her [ __ ]
while Florentine is giving her like I'm
literally a porno Greg [ __ ] but I forgot
Anthony in the limo me and the other
girl she actually just texted me
recently oh really
I might have been eating her [ __ ] or
she might have sucked my dick we were
newer couple I don't think I was [ __ ]
heard that okay and Anthony I remember
the girl and she was straddling here
yeah and straddling you oh they'll pull
the [ __ ] panties a side thing yeah so
I could get my [ __ ] out but I was
watching Anthony was giving her a pretty
good [ __ ] you I was a good that was fun
a nice you know you work the the limo
suspension you gotta work with it I
probably stopped yeah it was your
typical sitting thrush EastEnders
straddling that way kind of face to face
thing I was it worked out well yeah she
had that big flowing dress on or
whatever
was a wedding so we were all dressed on
fun wedding too disrespectful I was at
the Friars Club at dices kids bar
mitzvah that my girls like ow let's go
upstairs and I was like yeah oh you
[ __ ] Sonny and Lucy in the bathroom
you [ __ ] exploring and she was like
let's go re-watch yeah pop wants to see
you and I love that he just stays here
and listens to the door yeah makes a
little smirk in the book in the book
Sonny had a giant dick and [ __ ] him nah
that's why you see in the movie where
there's a moment where Sonny is missing
and the wife is doing this like opening
her hands she turns and looks and he's
not in his seat and she knows he's
[ __ ] that woman yeah in the book
Sonny had a giant dick and that woman
loose ooh he was [ __ ] in the bathroom
I went through this whole thing to her
[ __ ] was bigger than a normal [ __ ] and
she could take his dick and that was why
they were having this whole [ __ ]
affair oh but Sonny was an animal just
made him more of a fun yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah Sam's wedding was actually
really good I mean not for poor Jess
but Sam's wedding was it was one of the
best weddings was that was a lot of fun
wedding was the best one I've ever been
to that was the best overall wedding
it's great time it opens wedding his
wedding to Atlanta and you also had no
gift yeah but but the actual ceremony
was the best that I've been to nomes
wedding from the Comedy Cellar was
[ __ ] amazing yeah
and Sam had an amazing wedding a couple
when you do something different in a
wedding when it's not the same old yeah
yeah yeah fun it's a great punch it's
lame you just have someone you know
marry you horrible Tom Papa married
Lenny Marcus he was in the ceremony list
- listen Sarah Oh Kelly's able to marry
yeah yeah wait you know people do that
like I know my sister can do that she's
married a few a few people but like it's
almost like a side business oh no no no
I would have Tom do if I do if I got
married I would have Tom do it clever
yeah or bored Bob I would have a friend
do it to me it
seems less phony then there's been a
priest dude I'm like what are you gonna
give me a real ceremony I want a fun
street hooker come and read but she
wouldn't be legal in the state or I
would you got your rings [ __ ] got
your ring you got your love you got your
commitment anyone thinks this union
shouldn't be you know shut the [ __ ] up
yeah yeah come on dude stand up I'm
never got Bob do it yeah don't be all
smarmy just stand up what is he trying
to like get the tax deduction for riot
cast as a church yeah so uh yeah we have
time do it I would out of time or or Bob
Kelly or somebody I know do it or
[ __ ] Modi one of my comedian friends
you know just somebody who it would be
more fun that way obviously wouldn't be
in a Catholic Church perfect priest how
about they go who's the guy who the
[ __ ] anti gay lawmaker who just got
oh I love those [ __ ] a dude knock
[ __ ] on being gay got caught with this
dick in a bus or was he actually [ __ ]
when they walked it off it on him how do
you [ __ ] not kind of work that out so
no one's walking in on you yeah anti gay
ohio state lawmaker was all over
Craigslist looking for encounters with
other men yeah he are whatever you
thought he'd get out of prison
no encounters could mean anything well
when you look at his face you're like
wow I can't believe this guy was having
homosexual encounter yeah yeah and he
was what kind of anti-gay laws was the I
ain't know pro-lgbt digital marriage and
all that [ __ ]
gate law being anti-gay lawmaker I guess
he's just voting against gay marriage
and I don't know if it was his uh I
don't know if this is constituency or if
he was like one of these right right one
of these guys that uh he's he doesn't
like looking at it because he loves
doing
yeah maybe that's it he wants to be the
only one doing it oh yeah yeah call it
his dick in an ass how embarrassed
who walked in and what did you say okay
when you hear like that's that's sound
you know it's like oh no you're in
trouble how embarrassing is it when like
is there a moment when somebody walks in
and you're [ __ ] a guy in the ass and
you're like I'm gonna answer your
lawmaker didn't it blabbed it what are
you like oh uh and then try to explain
why you have your dick in a band shuffle
your papers really it's exactly what it
was [ __ ] yes I stand corrected
what was happening like what who walked
in I'm guess what somebody to do all of
it but they said it wasn't somebody he
worked with it was probably just some
guy he how do you pick a guy up off
Craigslist and haven't come to your
place of work maybe is that just easier
than cuz you can't cuz your own your
homes get your wife in it yeah maybe the
met was he married
I think so [ __ ] I was in Dallas with my
friend Justin opening for me and he went
on Grindr to find one dude by the time
that guy came through he'd already
figured out another guy and in the first
guys I said hey I'm available to it as
well already got somebody but you can
want to come over and like make a
three-cheese yeah okay and the first guy
was sucking I was like sure you're all
right and they had a threesome at 2:00
p.m. on a Wednesday just ruining the
sheets and the maid wouldn't talk to her
the rest of the week [ __ ] bad now was
he was he a guy who's promiscuous yeah
sounds the point where his boyfriend
asked him like listen I get it
don't give me AIDS was right and then
Justin was like I'll do the best I can I
can't promise holy [ __ ] does he I guess
Grindr you getting laid all the time on
the [ __ ] yeah gate has just decided
[ __ ] and [ __ ] that whole AIDS thing I
don't think I could get it yeah I really
think they they were Petra
for a while there watch he's a father
this practice drugs have prepped so you
don't get it and then there's the one
that you don't get it you're immune I
don't know if you're immune but it's
supposed to like cut it down like die 9%
and then there's the one that you can't
give it where which is what Charlie
Sheen I think said he was on where your
counters like zero you can't detect
makes it undetectable
I forget what that's called but you can
off well she yeah well you can like have
it and almost not pass it such long in
California's having a felony to not tell
people it should be a felony yeah that's
crazy
yeah they passed the law that said it's
not a felony anymore if you have sex
with somebody and don't tell them that
do you have a tip I should have to tell
someone
so is after the way out the door
yeah any other way if you sneeze I
should probably say something oh by the
way I think gonna say something you're
talking they got you you're doing the
scene the guy on the way out oh by the
way if you told me hey are you worried
about all this [ __ ] that's been coming
out about people and I'm saying this
together this guy who was harassed in
the allegations right I mean some of the
college rapes I've had no I feel like
there's there's things that I [ __ ] if
they wanted to change the tone and not
change the facts
I took a point yeah yeah changing the
tone that I really get in trouble for a
couple things but uh changing facts or
leaving a factor two out I'm like oh
yeah for sure they could get me if they
wanted but if somebody backs
yeah well like I was on the guys we [ __ ]
podcast and I got a vasectomy so I was
like I was like talking about it like
how was it about good like Mike so gonna
[ __ ] hold my ball and like really and
I'm like yeah and I showed them you show
you boss to everyone if they wanted to
be like he exposed himself right yeah
yeah there's a different tone though so
yeah [ __ ] scar yeah loads so I think
I asked this your load small
now I don't think so it tastes the same
you just got a Blom into tiny your hands
[Laughter]
[Music]
and your [ __ ] it's all metallic and
horrible you test your own load come on
I've gone down on girls after I've shot
loads in them but with I don't go in and
dig in I I really do
stick to the external part of it but
you'll taste some of it of course you
had some big boys on cleanup duty wrong
with that getting down there and clean
up your mess you were raised right
that was [ __ ] from like years ago when
anything just it you're so [ __ ]
turned on about everything that just
anything goes so you'd uh you had a
couple of girls try to sit on my face
it's one of the few things I can't get
into is he's really sucking a [ __ ]
that's like oh yeah once I come on back
to reality yeah it's just really it is
amazing right after that happens you're
just like yeah that's we're done here
I'm completely funding everything I just
said is not true rocky I don't even to
myself like even to me I thought we you
know let's just do this all night
[ __ ] it the second you guys like yeah I
think exactly where's the remote do you
have the remote it's okay I always have
to make her come first because as soon
as I'm finished I have no desire like I
literally I'm [ __ ] making excuses up
like oh my [ __ ] back I finished I
wish I'm gonna take a shower about 45
minutes like right afterwards like and
you'll be fast asleep when she gets back
in oh yeah
better than that movies on TV you're
falling asleep to it there's an
occasional woman especially in New York
where it's like as soon as you're done
they're like hey sure like see you later
Wow Wow
what I never had that in LA in New York
it's like a bunch where do you meet them
on the app sure that girls you know no
just people I meet or like a on Twitter
Instagram or something
never the woman didn't do anything did
you ever hook up we do you're dating me
I know you dated Natasha I do your date
other comedians or you never did hooks
up the few here and there yeah never
know but not that for any reason it's
just yeah I just never didn't ever had
that energy with them play their choice
all right fine
it's fun you get to talk about the same
[ __ ] you see them at shows I don't know
it just happens yeah yeah mmm yeah they
got a weird it's very hard just have a
rap with a female comic okay I think the
thing that makes me special does it make
me special I write a female comic Oh
like the thing that makes me specialist
I'm funny I have an interesting job
extra chromosome the comb the hairdo
forward yeah bi it doesn't make me
specify a female comic you know like
it's there's no there's no magic to me
around a female comic if they see that
yeah they understand how all the tricks
are done so it's like it doesn't mean
anything
oh yeah like someone who's not a
comedian so you know he's a funny guy
and he does that for a living and it's
interesting been around another comic
Tsugumi I feel bad for women sometimes
was like we break up and like but you
were so fun and I was like no I've been
fun before this is like really fun yeah
normally date yeah like C+ was like
great for you yeah one of the guys
normally didn't you uh we talk about
private stuff they talk about they're
not funny guys and I'm interesting guys
they don't know how to make fun of
things someone would tell me you ruined
me she does you ruined me like I go out
to restaurants with guys and they try to
be funny to the waiter and it's it makes
me angry
oh that's how unfunny they are cuz
they're doing like chip like puns and
not understanding yeah that's yeah
that's got to be pretty bad when you're
saddled with someone that thinks they're
really funny and they're not
hey wait a minute I love making a joke
to a waiter or some of them they don't
get it at all but it's like hey this
dish is really hot be careful grab it in
my face no no what are you doing yeah
boy yeah we we were through that a few
times
don't get the joke purposefully I like
to bother
I like purposely bombing in front of a
waiter just to make the whoever I'm with
uncomfortably is I big victim to that
when Jimmy does that it's so
embarrassing you feel compelled to
explain immediately to the waiter who he
is and why he's doing this
no he's an ounce I think you just look
like a [ __ ] or just don't even do a
check give me some I did with Kelsey I
mean Kelsey you're on the road I did
something with her um like just
something like the food will come and
like I eat most of it and uh just to say
that the waitress like she'll come over
and I'll be like I didn't like it I
think there was a problem with the food
you know politely laughs cuz you're
tipping and simple embarrassing is a
terrible joke and we know she doesn't
want to laugh and how many of those does
she have to listen to every laugh she's
got a laugh like that and you know I'll
tell I'll say like like the waitress
like you want some dessert and I'll
point of Kathleen on my wife tells me
I'm look like a fat pig so I just can't
and this is just going with it she
panics and you know and let's say that
there's great improv it really is the
word well the elevator rides were a
nightmare with Jim Norton because you'd
get in and if you were the only two in
the elevator and and it stopped on a
floor and more people got in he would
start a conversation in the middle like
we were having a conversation and be
like no it's not even a death sentence
anymore they have medicine don't worry
sweetie don't worry we'll get through
this and I'm sitting there laughing like
no he's
yeah well when you with the act like you
had some kind of mental problem and we
would we would like call him an idiot
stop doing that that was the old club
soda Kenny thing on the road with Dinah
with me Kenny used to play guitar no
just like I would have to add I'll act
almost autistic cuz I would laugh cuz
Kenny never aged times we'd go to
Starbucks and I would I would just touch
something and literally in a full
Starbucks this is no 1999 he would slap
me in the face and go stop touching that
and nobody ever came to my defense you
they were always afraid that this big
[ __ ] oh yeah guy they didn't know
what was the only time dice kept man as
we did in the airport one time and dice
got mad because we were there but yeah
Kenny was screaming at me at baggage
claim like I was talking to these couple
of girls about coming like you guys want
to come to the show and Kenny came over
and slapped me in the face in front of
the girls he's like stop talking to them
I'm sorry it was so fun security was
gonna throw you out yeah so happy yeah
so [ __ ] have to play you have to play
along all right sir yeah there's nothing
you can do you can't go like Kenny not
now yeah yeah can't say not now you
gotta just take it Road hijinx yeah
should now Frank and leave mmm leave
yeah office yeah
for what Dory's done I've never seen a
story disappear so quickly from the news
just because he's you know who he is
he's a very liberal guy and the the
networks and and some of the cable
outlets that are more liberal they just
the story just went away yeah they kind
of gave him I like it so I don't mind it
but they gave him a bit of a break yeah
the picture looks bad but it's like it's
through a flak jackets not really trying
to fondle yeah I don't think it was the
fact that he fell stop a little stop his
hands but I don't think it's the could
or couldn't make contact it's that if he
found that funny at all that shows a
blatant disregard for a woman's
get the you know
so I think that was more the problem
then Oh the vest wasn't it was too thick
yeah yeah yeah yeah if I see like like a
stature like a Michelangelo's David or
something and no one's taken I'm like oh
that show me like you do right it's
funny every time like there's nobody I'm
not gonna do that to be was carving that
he thought like people are gonna be
doing that thousand years later the
bigger and harder he did soft moments
had tiny dish they're all soft and
droopy and baby dicks for balls and a
tiny little baby dick they're all regal
they're not really particularly well
muscled and that stupid dick never hangs
past the balls here but it's not it's
not it's gonna be okay
it's not like because when it's when
it's somebody on the right mainstream
media will just keep pounding and
pounding it and demand that they are
removed from office
the removal stuff it's like I don't know
like he's worried more I'm like here's a
great time to not do anything because
he's up for election yeah so people can
decide yeah it really is kind of a good
example here now they can vote if they
believe it or don't believe it they'll
vote accordingly
yeah with and there you go it's like
when Cosby was happening people like we
got taking on The Cosby Show the people
didn't have any option so the network
had to get involved yeah but here it's
just like if they say we don't care then
they'll vote a mint and lavota man but
if they vote a man I hear there are
people that won't even they will remove
him immediately and the Senate might do
something yeah I think the allegations
are pretty strong it doesn't look good
really
yeah well then people wouldn't vote for
him right you know I don't know people
people maybe they should have the right
to I guess but if he's impossible the
Senate would want as a possible you know
a little weird they are yeah they might
error in judgment a little odd there is
this I've read some stuff that's just
nuts about Hollywood and politicians and
that that pedophilia cabal that's
supposedly going on in Hollywood and
everything it's some crazy stuff like
Corey Feldman in the club and Haim was
in it yeah that's their own yeah just
remember just around long time ago Jim
there was supposedly a a group of a very
important two men that were in the
movies and and they would take these
young boys and girls and have sex with
them it was called the group soda pop
club the soda pop media yeah the soda
pop club was a club specifically for
these youngsters in Hollywood but there
are other stories like there there was
one about Heather Heather O'Rourke
Heather O'Rourke was the little girl
from poltergeist oh yes supposedly had
been getting abuse and she was like five
and then there was a show called rocky
road that was on in the 80s it was one
of the last appearances she had on a
show and it was based on a beach kind of
an atmosphere so the little kids could
be put in bikinis without any suspicion
and they bring these executives in when
these guest stars would come on and they
would dance on a stage for these
executives while they jacked off this is
all obviously alleged it was a jacking
off together or in separate rooms
sitting in a theater because the the
studio they used to tape this show was
the same studio of these four jeopardy
so it was full of the seats like a
theater so people would sit in these
seats and just jack off I'll take the
red baby white for 200
[Laughter]
yes
so that was supposedly what they did and
they then they took Heather O'Rourke
wherever they took these girls to
physically assault them and it wound up
causing so much scarring in her bowels
that she got intestinal blockage that
ended up killing her about a year later
who died at 13 yeah Wow I thought she
was young like that that was I don't
heard that that's one of the stories
that are well they're all making the
rounds now there's another story about
George Lucas George Lucas George mas
yeah well this one is more there's an
interview with George Lucas he talks
about the script for Indiana Jones the
first one and there's a line where the
girl in it who was a woman
Allen Karen Allen yeah yeah drinking on
the table says I was a child I was in
love and he goes you knew what you were
doing and and George Lucas talks about
that she was supposed to be 12 when they
met when he was in his like 20 late 20s
early 30s she was supposed to be a
twelve-year-old that was the back story
that was the back story that Lucas
wanted to do and actually had written
into why that and then they changed it
more on that car but then I'm watching
I'm watching American Graffiti last
night yeah and and I hadn't heard
anything good movie George Lucas of
shores and the coolest guy in the movie
is Milner the the race car guy he spends
the whole movie driving around in a car
with an 11 year old and there is some
dialogue there that's a little weird why
do you think there might have been some
underlying weird thing like George Lucas
and and some of these Hollywood types
are putting their wants and and needs
into some of these movies that's right
she was always that girl it was she was
that Mackenzie Phillips yeah okay yeah
who by the way was [ __ ] by her father
yeah John Phillips Jones
and passed around now in the Hollywood
and music community I didn't know she
yes around by her dad she what public
with that crazy it was like a known
thing but his pre love like predated all
this but this is some of the real here's
a post-dated into the teenager yeah this
she was really young here in the put in
the teenage years they were [ __ ]
maybe maybe then too but as a teenager
yeah
it's it's really strange but they're
it's all these things on various you
know 4chan and reddit wow that's a
greatness nuts that all these weird
connections with your kids in movies
going on back then non-stop when I
couldn't get caught right you couldn't
get caught and rampant nobody talked the
parents just handed these kids over be
nice to the man be nice to the nice man
so I didn't I didn't what else was yours
Lucas I I heard none of that well those
are the only one I heard was from
Indiana Jones but watching that last
night I'm like he put the lead guy well
you know it's a huge ensemble cast but
the cool guy the entire show he's with a
[ __ ] eleven-year-old well it was the
point of that did they say why they were
hanging out yeah well he pulls up next
to a car with chicks in it and he's
trying to get one of the girls in his
car and she goes well I'm going steady
how about you take this girl's sister
and then he goes okay cuz he couldn't
see and then the girl just runs out and
hops in the car is like ah what are you
12 or something like that but they spend
the whole night together and it kind of
have fun and and he gives her a little
trinket from his car and gives her a
kiss on the cheek before she runs into
the house and says how she feels like
they're going steady and it's just a
weird there's a little bit of sexual
energy there well look at the
professional yeah yeah yeah although
right yeah wasn't a part of the script
that they were [ __ ] and they changed
a little bit I usually shut it off when
I'm finished
thanks very much Travis Travis I came in
to grab my [ __ ] Oh Travis says one of
the most interesting things about
Raiders of the Lost Ark is we have the
transcript of the 78 meeting oh yes
should we do the the story meeting and
then you go to the ideas behind Marion
Raven wouldn't have the two characters
no
each other yeah so I'll be uh Lawrence
Kasdan do you want to be George Lucas
obviously I'll be Spielberg oh yeah you
know yeah you be Spielberg all right uh
I like it if they already had a
relationship at one point because they
don't have to build it I was thinking
that this old guy could have been his
mentor he could have known this little
girl when she was just a kid
had an affair with her when she was 11
and he was 42 he hasn't seen her in 12
years now she's 22 it's a real strange
relationship he's 35 and he knew her 10
years ago when he was 25 and she was
only 12 it would be amusing to make her
slightly young at the time and
promiscuous she came on to him 15 is
right on the edge I know it's an
outrageous idea but it is interesting
she's uh once she's 16 or 17 it's not
interesting anymore but if she was 15
and he was 25 they actually had an
affair the last time they met and she
was madly in love with him and he she
has pictures of him now that was the
transcript from one of the scripts for
real yeah but yeah but you don't know
but you don't know the tone of it again
it might have been creepy or it might
have been uh you know yeah she came on
to him like this peon [ __ ]
well in what ended up in the movie was
her saying I was a child I was in love
and and he goes you knew what you were
doing so there's this it is it does
exist kind of thing they can't they
wanted to cast a younger girl than her
who's in that than Karen Allen because
if you take ten years off of her she was
maybe 30 at the time so she was laid off
yeah so who knows but it's just a weird
like that's a good point that's an odd
[ __ ] thing to say let's take our
hero our movie hero and say he was
[ __ ] a an 11 year old when he was 25
is it an excuse to get to do flashbacks
to get kids on the set or like with
Mackenzie Phillips is it like hey this
would be a reason to keep her around and
it does kind of work in the story you
know in Hollywood they do want just like
people that like on set if they think
yeah yeah and your character and I think
like you I think the kids on set
especially during the 80s a lot of those
kids shows is what they they've been
talking about on a lot of these message
boards and whatnot that it was just out
of hand
yeah they would they would put they
would make shows that were specifically
kid oriented as far as the cast goes and
the guest stars that they would pull on
whether the show sucked or not it would
get picked up just so these guys could
have a place to jerk off and and
sexually Wow yeah that seems to be what
was going on it's hard the way and I'll
go back to a club to a city it's not
that good or doesn't pay me well if
there's some chick there that Fox Bay
went to Akron Ohio to [ __ ] once please I
would never I've never been back I had
never been there before you hopped on a
plane yeah I've hopped on planes for
[ __ ] yeah like lame the plane to [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's how you know you really
want to [ __ ] somebody when you actually
go through security yeah oh my god damn
I might want to blow all over this
person yeah yeah did you only do it once
I remember maybe two times maybe two
times I did I remember the person yeah
yeah tell you she on her way
yeah oh Christ that's right no no she
wound up yeah cuz we were done and then
she wound up showing up she drove from
Akron to my house really and she's like
I'm in your driveway
that's awful this is good yeah I call it
I took coltan I told no thanks well you
are gonna have to leave right after you
blow me
our traffic together no she got a little
less clingy as they say yeah some people
dinging yeah some people do right they
get a bit oh yeah yeah a bit at the hip
yeah I said no this was not what it
wasn't then what do you do yeah he
[ __ ] him I'm weak what do you think
of now there's that [ __ ] sweeter
champions that [ __ ] out there saying
that did Jack Ruby say that there was a
he said watch the fireworks
what's that he [ __ ] kids he was a
bagman for the Dallas mob I'm just
quoting the unsafe work environment for
women he did he really was I mean yeah
thank God he's passed away because he'll
be uh dragged through the mud publican
no they said he has to watch the
fireworks just hours before Kennedy's
assassination no was he talking about
that or something else I don't know oh
he said watch the fireworks yeah
would the assassination Oh like he might
have known something was gonna happen he
made comments on the morning of the
JFK's assassination to an FBI informant
that suggested he knew something was
gonna happen he was eventually oh okay I
hate when they say what he did you got
the TV they're saying cult leader
Charles man we know we [ __ ] know hope
later two days later I okay I say they
just saying he said watch the fireworks
November November no no when did JFK get
shot
November oh really yeah I figured the
date November 22nd was a 22nd yeah
November 28th 1963 place in car light
head get away watch the fireworks
very good one Kennedy it's like one of
those things Eve those things that you
put in the street you lined up and just
goes right to Parkland Memorial
yeah that's well you know oh is that
from some of the new stuff that came out
yeah one of the ones that and they said
Heavenly heavily redacted in the old
thing all or something I hate that
redacted [ __ ] that stinks house just
like not releasing all of it yeah
national security they use a lot what's
still going on right exactly
yeah why can't they tell us what people
said what they saw they don't want us to
know what's coming back to the
governor's yeah no she's fine not even
like one guy raised the point or maybe
incompetence or something incompetent
like if you're the kid of family members
who helped like our country against
Castro you still have family in Cuba
like all right there's certain things
where your family may have helped the
u.s. and you still have living family
members in those countries and the
government might hurt your surviving
yeah then you might want to me yeah
exactly but that's it that's it I mean
like when you whenever you hear
something like well you don't know maybe
the government yeah Jerry has anything
like that ever come out like 20 years
later like okay 9 now right here's what
we couldn't tell you I don't know I I
think it happened an excuse I think it
happened exactly like they said it did
in the joke yeah yeah that's one magic
loogie the new chip chip person podcast
is up by the way it's an odd one he's an
awful host yeah oh my god he is terrible
he's difficult to work with but I I have
feelings that I like doing the show as a
matter of fact I think I'm taping this
week tomorrow night tomorrow night yeah
I'll be taping but I missed Sunday who
was on I was Sam came on and we'll
savants who people love oh my I'm so
vents is perfect on it and Christina was
not available
so Liz from the Comedy Cellar came on I
think
and uh you Christina people love she's
great on it but yeah I'm not available
as she was doing some set Christina
Palumbo no she uh she liked she works
here and she's working J Thomas's show
and Bobo I've tried to get on but
apparently he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
being around her anymore he won't come
on the show yeah he really is yeah he
does I don't know why it was like chip
he has a war to get [ __ ] ugly that
will is hilarious that show because the
like chip loves will cuz we'll will say
the dumbest [ __ ] yeah I've ever heard
he's free him and chip just see eye to
eye it's yeah yeah and he's silly on it
and chip just complements him constantly
tells him how he should be on every show
and it was just great yeah so the new
ones up it's a weird one but I liked it
I like when they're a little weird they
have no flow once in a while you need
that that's what that's what he is
it's great chips not an antihero not no
flowy stinked I want to see 30 cool to
ride cats YouTube I want to say 32 or 33
that's great it's fun to do mass
murderer
cult leader Charles Manson they ought to
add two things in is he technically a
mass murderer I cast you to ass mess I
guess a lot of people but but you know
again he didn't murder those people yeah
he had people do it so I don't know if
that makes you a mass murderer 32-bit
hats
I think because I mentioned it somebody
made a montage of your hats falling off
they do come off once an awful lot that
means somebody some poor soul had to go
over every episode and watch every in a
row to get right and watch your hat come
off yeah I don't think I don't eat
something I want Denny that came here I
thought Danny was gonna be in the Denise
Falcone yeah but he won't I guess he's a
[ __ ] away to be invited what so we're
hanging with an tyre
he's not allowed to Camillus I invited
yeah